A really great way of exploring Australia is by car,...
...and the southern coast of Western Australia is as good a place as any.
The starting point is the capital city of Western Australia, Perth,...
...no doubt one of the most isolated cities in the world.
The interesting thing is that it is closer to Singapore...
...than it is to the other side of Australia.
Two of the world's great oceans meet here,...
...the Indian and the Pacific Ocean.
This influences the weather,...
...and it is usually cooler here than at the east coast.
The meeting of the two oceans...
...also makes this region a popular spot for surfers.
In addition, during July and November,...
...most areas of the largest Australian state...
...are covered in an inferno of colors,...
...as the wildflowers start to blossom, even up to the doorsteps of Perth.